awesome thank you so much Michael it's
so good to be in the space and so good
to share with you all I'm a huge fan of
Michael's work Michael recently he
probably I just had to say that
um there was uh your piece that you did
with um you know anti-social behavior
um and trying to like uncover the extent
of it that you all did it was probably a
couple years ago I think you all
presented that at cscw
um and I wish I I loved that piece I
wish I had that piece
um 10 years ago you know I was like I
needed this 10 years ago because I think
you know as a qualitative researcher and
Scholar you know I don't you know I
don't do statistics you know I don't do
the quantitative stuff and so usually
when I'm in space is trying to talk
about like a problem folks always say
well what's the extent of the problem
and I couldn't and I didn't have it and
I think I was doing this work a little
bit too early you know before you know
like you know external peer research has
done some stuff here we got data we got
numbers now right
um and I really and I love that piece so
much so I love sharing that and adding
that and talking about that whenever you
know folks want to talk about like
trolling and you know looking at like
anti-social behaviors inside spaces so
it's wonderful work Michael and I'm so
glad to to share space with you all
thanks for having me that's so great
thank you for having me thank you
absolutely
um I I never know where to start with
these things you know because there are
so many different ways where I can you
know take these conversations and
um and and first I'm just I'm really
glad to be able to share space with
folks like you all you know especially
you know compsi engineering folks
um because you know we speak different
languages you know I think and I think
that's one of the things that um that I
love that we're sharing space so we can
kind of talk with each other instead of
like over and across each other
um I I got I um a few One intersectional
tech first came out
um there was a uh computer science
professor at Yale a lovely human being
but he laughed at how I was talking
about algorithms in my book
intersectional Tech
um and I think you know we we've you
know he was he he was laughing because I
think he realized the disconnect that
happens like when people are trying to
make sense of algorithms and like what
algorithms like actually are
um and and I think that like and and
what he shared he had shared there was
an excerpt in intersectional Tech that
where um there were some black men
talking with one another and I think
that they were on social media and they
were getting like a bunch of like spammy
kind of content and somebody made the
comment inside that that chat that said
well you got to get your algorithms
right so you know it's one of those one
of these lessons where we think that we
can manipulate like the algorithm right
where we think that our choices and our
behaviors and the things that we do and
then we have control of an algorithm
ourselves right and so it was really
interesting you know when um Professor
Kim you know the Cs professor at Yale he
was like no that's not how any of this
works you know so it was really good
just to hear that but I think that there
is really um what's important is that
when people don't have like the answers
or they don't know the how or why of
something the human brain will fill in
the blanks you know automatically you
know based off if it's real imagined or
perceived you know our brains will
interpret things you know and we will
fill in like a lot of those blanks so I
feel like a lot of my work is kind of
like that in between space if things are
happening on the technical side on the
the infrastructure side on that on the
system side and then these users have no
idea like what's happening and then so
they're they're they're
um they're expressing themselves and
especially now they're using social
media to kind of talk about what they're
seeing and what they're feeling and
experiencing and I think there's like a
lot of value in that that I think the
industry you know hopefully the industry
is starting to pay more attention to and
you know beautiful folks like you all
you know you all are are able to
um you know to to interact and to
contribute in those spaces like so um
because you all are like a part of also
like the bridging of the Gap you know
for like folks like me and like industry
because you all are going to go in there
um in beautiful beautiful ways I have
some slides here I can share them but if
those if you saw if y'all if y'all have
seen me talk you know I'm terrible with
with with PowerPoint I'll go off on a
tangent I'll just go somewhere and it's
neither here nor there
um so just just just follow along
um so
um here's um some of my books um yeah I
can tell I like I like color I like
colorful books that actually was
incongruent with publishing for a long
time you know because I know there are a
lot of these Publishers are like no we
don't want all those colors this is a
simple book
um but so I advocated and I fought for
colors on these books
um uh they're eye-popping but um I I
wanted to a lot of my work really is
like situated on just this convergence
and this conflation and the collapsing
of like boundaries you know between
people and spaces and the technologies
that they use so I really like looking
at like this hybrid space of like where
do we meet you know when we're on our
online and offline selves you know
what's like that hybrid space like um of
what we create and what we do and what
we make and how we think about the world
and so my early work was really focused
on you know I was in gaming spaces
trying to figure out you know you know
the gaming technology was Innovative and
it was going so fast and just seeing how
people like connected with it
um some of that early work really
focused on like um there's a theory the
diffusion of innovation Theory
um that's near and dear to my heart it's
one of my favorite but I really wanted
to think about you know how does our
identity influence like the ways that we
like adopt Technologies and how we use
these Technologies and of course there
was um you know there are some a lot of
This research uh influence like digital
divide scholarship of where you know we
talk about you know you know Race
Matters gender matters like our economic
situations matter you know class matters
right and so I was really fascinated at
at um uh because I also during that time
this is like grad school it's like 2007
2008. I remember reading something and
basically a lot of that scholarship was
kind of situating black folks Black Folk
is like the the poster children from the
digital divide and that was just
incongruent with my reality of what I
knew about the spaces that I was
occupying uh what I knew about folks who
were inside those spaces I'm like you
know I'm like we aren't the poster
children actually you know black folks
were pretty Savvy and this was actually
also like a few years after the um the
million woman March and we don't talk
about the million woman March that much
but you know it was kind it was done
after the Million Man March
um and it really it was it was in the
90s and it showcased just the the Techno
savviness of like black women like to be
connected like with networks uh they
organized an entire rally using fax
machines
um and so you know I thought it was like
really interesting and really cool you
know just how they were using like the
technologies that were that were like um
afforded to them right and so I think a
lot of my work just really wanted to um
put put marginalized minoritized folks
you know back into the conversation so
we can see what have they contributed
what have they said how have they
utilized these Technologies
um and so that that piece that I did
around like diffusion of innovation you
know I wanted to see how do um how do we
learn new technologies you know
um how do we uh adapt to the changes
like especially like with the continued
changes like around technology how are
we adapting to that so in the diffusion
of innovation like literature there are
you know folks who are like early
adopters
um and then there are like people who
are called away laggards right I'm sure
they've probably updated these terms by
now but I was fascinated by that
um and and seeing as how you know black
folks have been black and brown folks
are really Savvy in like these gaming
spaces it was just interesting just to
see you know how they came into the
space and why they stay in a space that
may not be a space that was created for
them
um especially with the continued
advances of like this technology and
whenever you know folks start talking
with one another and you know the spaces
guy you know pretty trolley real quickly
you got pretty races pretty quickly but
then people stayed you know so I became
fascinated and just trying to make sense
of you know um of the communities that
people created inside those spaces how
they connect with one another and also
then then why they stay but in that
piece that um that I focused on
um I I realized that there are some you
know some folks who you would call like
the the interlop shooters or The
Interlopers like in the space you know
these folks who were like the early
adopters and then they share that
information with other folks so there
was this one person in particular if
anybody's read my work it's the
character I think it's Smith and Wesson
um he is the person who you know he goes
he has the resources like to go to the
um to go to the conferences to go to
like the e3s when he pre-existed
whatever's happening with E3 now my
goodness
um you know so he had um he had the
means to go to those spaces and then he
would bring back those information uh to
the community and it would disperse it
in really interesting ways
um and it got more Savvy with it as
social media when thinking about like
convergence but whenever um you know
social media started to permeate in
gaming spaces it became a lot easier for
him to then share that information so he
he's built like this pretty big you know
platform
um of where you know he is like like
this gaming Guru really like for black
and brown communities it's really
beautiful
um but what I what I also something else
that you know kind of anchors my work
um you know I talked to you all about
how I like I'm situated like in this
hybrid space of where you know I'm
fascinated with the offline meeting like
the online and seeing what gets created
in there but I just recognize the
importance of the the physical space IRL
I recognize that it's a space that's not
neutral so there's really no way that we
can create these neutral experiences
these neutral Technologies you know
because of of course and this
scholarship is everywhere now you know
because we bring you know all of these
we bring in our assumptions we bring in
our biases we bring in you know the
world in which we we exist and we live
in we bring our perspectives inside that
um and then we um but then because it's
like a technical space you know it's not
the same and so we refashion it and
remix it in a really particular way
um one of the things that uh an example
that I'll talk about that some of you
have heard me speak I talk a lot about
this Pokemon go example and that is
really just this amazing um for those of
you who know Pokemon go uh you know it's
this geolocation survey is that you use
like mobile technologies right and so
it's this this really interesting space
that allows me to really just think
through all these things just in that
one place I'll talk about it in in just
a second
um also just to get Folks up to speed
about you know like my background you
know in the kai talk for those that that
may have heard the guy talk you know I
talk about how gaming is like this
Canary in the coal mine and that if we
would have paid attention more attention
so like what was happening in the gaming
space we could have preemptively solved
like some of the issues and the problems
that we have now I love talking about
the connect the connect came out in 2009
and the connect
um you know the connect only wanted to
play with certain bodies and certain
people right the connect didn't read
bigger bodies the connect didn't read
folks like they had darker skin
um you know if somebody had like um uh
it wouldn't read um like if you have
like larger breasts it wouldn't read
like your your chest area it was really
just a space that was made and created
you know by a particular like
demographic right
um and so it was really interesting you
know when people were you know blowing
the whistle on this and how many folks
like just weren't really like paying
attention they were like no your
lighting's bad you just don't have
enough space
um it was it after that talk somebody
came up to me he said he worked on the
connect he was really I don't think he
did nobody knew him
um but he came up to me and he was
telling me how the connect actually
worked and he confirmed what I was
saying you know so me even thinking
about like Michael's shirt right now
Michael has on a black shirt the connect
in those days would not have read or
rendered his body it would have just had
him he would have just been like a head
you know kind of like floating in like
the Multiverse or whatever you know so
it was just really interesting how far
along we've come but if we would have
paid a little bit more attention there
than we would have been able we would
have been ahead of that conversation
around like body recognition racial you
know facial recognition
um and we would have been able to uh not
be shocked by what's happening like with
project green light in Detroit or you
know we wouldn't have been shocked about
you know Alexa you know making these
inappropriate jokes right we would have
been like well yeah the the technology
is like a reflection of like all of our
biases because we're building and we're
embedding them in there I'm even
thinking about Microsoft hey y'all
remember the chat bot that Microsoft had
right you know we weren't I don't know
why we were shocked then like of course
this is what's gonna happen when you let
loose like this learning machine that's
gonna go onto Twitter she's gonna learn
those things because that's how like
people operate that's how people like
speak and interact in those kinds of
spaces
um but I really think gaming gave us
like a good little platform so we can
think about you know what the spaces
might look like
um all of these things I'm trying to
like go real quick and catch everybody
up a lot of the work that that I I did
led me to this framework of like
intersectional game design because when
I talk to a lot of these companies
they're always asking well keshana all
that is well and good in theory that's
nice it's good to know that but how can
we put this like into practice right
um and so I always you know ask the
question like well when you're creating
these experiences like who are you
creating them for like who's your
audience like you're not creating
Universal experiences because you're
still gonna exclude some folks right and
so I think that these gaming companies
have to be intentional about who they're
creating things for and they actually
should just say you these folks it
wasn't designed with that person in mind
you know it wasn't designed with
disabled people in mind and um because I
think if we're we're thinking
intersectionally we're also thinking
about
um accessibility can everybody play this
game and if everybody can't play this
game you have to I think a company
should you know um operate writing from
like an ethic of care they should
actually articulate you know those kinds
of things that's what an intersectional
game design will call for
um and also in thinking about like
Aesthetics you know we have to think
about what things look we have to think
about the sound and the haptic
experiences and the Sonic experiences
and the mechanical
um Aesthetics you know I was spending a
little bit of time like with Karma
scales early in my life and I'm like
these decisions just make no sense you
know why would you create like
decision-making trees with like these
decisions like in mind there was one
there was a game I was playing Infamous
Second Son of where basically we have
the main character you we have to make a
decision to save ourselves or to save
like um or like if we save ourselves it
will destroy like an entire tribe and
I'm like you know what's what's the
purpose in that
um uh thinking about like Frameworks uh
Hawkins I can't remember their first
name but Hawkins has a really
interesting and Powerful framework
um that Ludo narrative dissonance that
allows me to help really make sense
sense of these design choices inside a
game of where you know those decision
making that decision making has nothing
to do with like the gameplay and how
those are like incongruent within one
another and they really make no sense um
and so I think it's really important for
you know folks who are designing these
experience like to think about that like
will this design Choice like impact then
then like the narrative and oh another
example I should have put this up there
and The Last of Us anybody play the game
The Last of Us I wish I could see the
whole room I can't see everybody but
um so the last of us is a really
interesting experience
so towards the the end of The Last of Us
two I believe it's the interaction with
Nora so you're Ellie and Nora and you've
fallen and Ellie is the character where
she's she's immune you know she she can
be around you know like the um the
zombies and you know she's not gonna get
that the disease that everybody else is
getting because she's immune to this
um and so Ellie
um is a character who is like who's
there in the space they fall into like
the spores din with the zombies
um and then
um but they were they were battling they
were fighting but basically uh Ellie
ends up killing Nora and then basically
we have to like press X as we're like
hacking and slicing her and I'm just
like this is wild like just the the
visceralness of that was just
incongruent I'm like there was no need
for us like just just have the death
happen there's no need for us to like
press X so I can engage with that I
don't think a lot of designers really
think about those kinds of choices
um Battlefield 1 is also this beautiful
experience usually it's easier just to
QR code that so if you can QR code that
that's going to take you to a YouTube
channel
um uh of the opening scene of this game
Battlefield one
now I I think it's a beautiful
experience if you um if you have some
time to like look at it or just you know
kind of listen to me as it's um and just
keep it on uh keep keep it on mute
um but you're I was excited about this
game because it's the first time that I
think like a black regiment was featured
like on a triple a studio you know kind
of game and so I was just and it's the
Harlem Hell Fighters you know who are a
very successful in in terms if you can
be successful in war you all know what I
mean so sorry but
um if you they're a successful
um you know regimen of black and Puerto
Rican men who were fought who fought in
World War one now when I played this
game I was excited and knowing Shooters
I thought I was it was just going to be
one of multiple characters that we could
play and we would engage you know with
his narrative but what they actually did
was create hyper invisible death there
was so much Black Death in that opening
because you started with one character
and then the game kills you like so I
remember as I was playing I was playing
this game in my life when I was at um I
was in at Eastern Kentucky University
um and so we were playing this game but
we recognized that um you know as soon
as we went out you know the the shots
were immediate and instant it it took a
while for us to generate our health back
so the game was designed to kill us
right
um and then because they basically
wanted to um wanted to Showcase this
Memorial memorium that they had designed
so when you die a name pops on the
screen and you're celebrating or
honoring you like this person's like
death now this game came out in 2016 so
the Optics are terrible right remember
what I was talking about authentic
experience like who are these
experiences for so in 2016 this was like
really at the height of the movement for
black lives
um I think a couple of things that
um
and and so when this game comes out
you're basically witnessing like the
final moments of like this black
person's life right and it was really
hard to like engage in that amount of
like Black Death that was out of your
control and so I likened it to the other
things that we were seeing on social
media of like hashtag Black Death
everywhere of where you have this
hypervisibility you know this trauma
porn you know almost you know that
that's like happening and then the game
created this experience for us right
um and so here in this moment where we
wanted to celebrate it it was just hard
to
um given the overwhelmingness of of the
of the emotions and the death in in that
game
um some of the other things um there's
no segue in any of this I'm just kind of
giving you like a hodgepodge of all all
my work and what I'm interested in
um I got really interested in reporting
structures as well
um shifting gears here
um I got interested in reporting
structures because whenever I I started
most of my work most not I started still
am most of my work is in the console
gaming space you know so I don't really
do much like in the PC space
um I think that there's so much Beauty
and value especially in in a console you
know because it's it's not a computer
but it's not just a video game you know
it's this really remarkable Dynamic you
know multi-mediated experience
um that uh that that serves you know a
particular function right
um so I was really interested um in the
early days of my work where you know
folks were talking about the sexism and
the racism that they experience
um and I'm I'm because I'm big you know
I I guess I guess I'm kind of platform
studies I don't know I don't I don't
know names I don't know labels I just do
work and I just do me
um but I was really fascinated
um in how one would go about reporting
um harms that happen to them in a game
right
and so I spent some time you know across
PlayStation and and Xbox you know those
those shoe the the the big two consoles
right
um I spent time across those two just
looking at
um the reporting systems looking at the
language that was there and uh they're
on those reporting systems
um and they say a lot right I think a
lot of people assume that these
reporting systems are neutral there's a
lot of valuation here an evaluation I
mean like a value system you know this
indicates
um what a platform cares about
um what um
and what matters to them
so this is one of the Xbox one of the
early reporting systems like an Xbox
right and so if we were to go in and
report somebody I can report for spam I
can report for their bio or their
location I can report for cheating their
player name or gamertag picture quitting
early on sporting behavior and voice
communication right and so I was
fascinated at how these are designed
I was fascinated at the language that's
used
um because I think that you know
um
these these phrases are doing a lot of
work but they're doing very little right
um early on voice communication actually
was added much later right
um because a voice chat came later in a
lot of these systems right it wasn't it
wasn't one of the I think voice chat in
in Xbox came I think around like 2004
um but the game had went nope it was
live I can't remember it went live and a
few years later voice chat but anyway
and also now there's an option for
gender-based harassment that came after
um uh after gamergate you know the
harassment campaign like against women
inside the gaming space so there's an
option for gender-based harassment but
for the longest time there were only
options to like report cheating now that
lets you know what what what a platform
cares about if they're they're like okay
we got to do something about the
cheating in the space and so I was
asking and trying to reach out to try to
find out well if somebody experiences a
sexism or racism where do they go and
voice communication came in there and so
people said well you can you can report
in voice communication and the a whole
host of other options like come up but I
think that there is a disconnect in how
people might um explain or describe the
experiences that they're having in a
space
so I remember
um um uh harassment was an option that
came up eventually I think probably 2016
or 2017. I think you can see harassment
and what I realized and I didn't I
didn't anticipate was that there's going
to be
um some racial differences in how people
make sense of harassment so when I was
talking to black women in particular
they never would have described the
things that they were experiencing in
that that space is harassment
they um and I thought that was
interesting I was like so so whenever
you experience like
um like you know uh sexism in the space
you know if people are you know asking
you to make sandwiches or perform sexual
favors you know things like that how
would you describe that uh one woman
actually said she said well that's just
boy I ain't reporting that
because it's not I'm used to it it's
like such a normal thing so here are a
couple things that were like you know um
I'm trying to basically coalesce in my
mind
they wouldn't have used the language of
harassment but they had also normalized
their experience to the point where they
didn't even utilize the reporting
systems so there's no way to get this
information you know to to the
stakeholders in the space so the
Platforms in the space
because I even remember there was a few
years ago where Xbox had even put out
like a press release that said you know
we don't have an issue of racism in our
space because there's like this culture
like well this is normal it always
happens and the system's not going to do
anything about it and so here we are
like inside this Loop and I'm like this
can be reality this can't this can't be
right right
I let's fast forward a little bit do I
have okay I didn't of course I didn't do
this right
um they're fast forward a little bit uh
there's a game Friday the 13th
Friday the 13th it's it's basically like
a copy and paste of the movies y'all
aren't even old enough to remember
Friday the 13th I think they've had like
Rebus yes Mike yes you're not
so it's like legit copy and paste and it
was beautiful I was so excited you know
my my 80s kid self was very um looking
forward to this right so when we were
playing Friday the 13th you know you can
play as a counselor or you play as some
of the jasons you know they have
different iterations of Jason so
um one of the iterations of Jason's the
part two Jason that's the Jason that has
the pillowcase over his head
um and
sadly he got co-opted by um by some
folks of ill will inside the gaming
space so they used him as like a clan
member Jason like he's like the KKK I
mean this is like his clan hood that
he's got on his head
now during this time you know talk about
the different Innovations inside the
space Xbox had just introduced
um a uh a feature where you can utilize
hashtags to find other folks to play
with so one of the hashtags that was
created
um was hashtag make Crystal Lake great
again
um where people of ill will would go in
and play together and utilize Clan
member Jason
um and kill all of the characters of
color and the women
and and so the researcher in me was like
of course I'm not shocked at this the
human in me was like I'm not shocked the
researcher in me was like I'm fascinated
I want to know more about this so I
reached out to the folks who were like
you know utilizing you know Clan part
two Jason
um and asking them you know why are you
doing this why are you engaging in these
kinds of behaviors and so they called me
the n-word because I was playing as a
black woman in the game I was playing as
Vanessa
um and so you know they called me like
the n-word I was like why did you say
that because I'm just in research about
them so again I'm a person who
normalizes all this right because I've
seen it a whole lot and it's sad but you
know just the re I'm like these folks
are gonna make me Rich they're going to
give me plenty of content for my next
book so that's just that's the mode I'm
operating on and so um I sent a text I I
text the person because I can you can do
voice based chat you can do text-based
chat inside
um these these uh these platforms so I
said why did you call me and I spelled
out the n-word
I was banned immediately
I was banned um and I'm like hmm okay uh
this is surely a mistake because I
didn't use the n-word with like any Mal
intention right so I'm like surely
there's an easy fix
so I tried to reach out to Xbox
enforcement
um
I don't think there were that many
humans behind the scenes here right and
so I'm like okay what is happening here
I remember a few a few months before you
know these these platforms are always
trying to do something to kind of curb
to kind of curb the harms that people
might might experience
um and so there was also this trend for
a lot of these platforms to go zero
tolerance when it comes to racism but
basically all they were gonna do is Ban
the inward
now think about like who are you
creating these experiences for they
didn't think that banning having like a
blanket ban on the n-word would
negatively impact black folks who would
reclaim the language and use the n-word
in their everyday practices so you had
these huge swaths of black folks who
were getting banned for using like the
n-word
um and so we're and so I'm guessing you
know there's whatever algorithm or
machine learning thing like I said this
is y'all stuff it's not stuff I know so
I'm just telling you all the problems so
y'all can help me fix it
um but basically they didn't anticipate
you know
um or uh they didn't really like
acknowledge like the different ways in
which the n-word would be used so they
had to fix that but here I was a black
person getting banned because the
harmony happened to me
um and then I was banned in that space
and I went on Twitter I popped off and
then I eventually got unbanned but I was
just really fascinated because there was
no way to really like report or explain
to the to the system what had happened
to me but then the system you know
recognized you know this like pretty
easily you know so they're um you know
so if folks are motivated to do things I
realize that stuff is actually actually
possible in the space I don't mind for
time because I can just keep you know
Michael you know that I'll just be talk
I'll just be talking I'll forget like
all my time
um we're at about noon uh we have till
12 30 including discussion so most
speakers will go until like I don't know
12 20 or so 20 minutes and then we can
chat okay and also just keep an eye on
that Google doc because if folks are
engaging and have like a lot of
questions you know I don't mind stopping
this you know so I can hear from you all
and so we can chat chat with those folks
so just keep keep me posted on that part
Michael sounds great okay perfect good
deal
um one of the other things that I'm
really interested in is like how of
course part of like the the diffusion of
innovation you know kind of um project
that I'm doing is looking at Pathways
like to utilizing like new technologies
and I've really become fascinated with
the Reliance on mobile technologies and
mobile devices but I'm also fascinated
with how like a lot of these new
technologies rely on public the
infrastructure in order to support it
and how those things are not always
aligned with one another and so I
learned this whenever I was in Chicago I
talked to you all a little bit about
Pokemon go before but I want to spend a
little bit of time telling this because
this is like where I've I've been I've
been thinking about this like a whole
lot trying to put you know words to it
trying to put some Frameworks to it to
really to really make sense of of what's
happening so whenever I was in Chicago I
was at the University of Illinois
Chicago you know for a little while
um right right before covet you know
during covet
um and so I got connected with some
young folks um at on the south side of
Chicago through the public library so
there was like an after-school kind of
thing happening
um because I love doing work with like I
love my service work is usually with
youth I actually don't publish
scholarship like around around those
around the things that I do with youth
until this thing happened here and I
gotta go through the IRB process and all
that stuff but anyway
um I was fascinated with Pokemon go for
a lot of reasons right is I loved that
it got folks uh back into the physical
environment right and I just love I told
you all like I really I exist like at
this um where the offline and online
meet like these hybrid spaces so this
was like one of those examples that just
allowed me to see you know what's
happening in that hybrid spaces where
the online meets the offline right
um and so so I was excited so I went to
the Pokemon go Fest and these young
folks that I work with on the south side
of Chicago invited me there sadly they
weren't able to get in because
um you know whenever whenever the city
of Chicago and most cities you know see
groups of black men they think there's
going to be some some Mal intent on
their part and then they get kind of
shoot and pushed away right so
um we had to go back down to the South
side because I didn't want them
experiencing that anti-blackness in that
way and from what I knew about Pokemon
go I'm like well we can play this
anywhere right we don't need to be at
this Festival in order to play Pokemon
go I was wrong
so what what I when we went back down to
Inglewood like to play Pokemon go
um we weren't there was one stop
um and there there was one location and
this was actually a Confederate statue
in this park uh south side of Chicago I
was just like ain't no way we're gonna
go and hang out with this Confederate
statue she's not on my watch and so I I
looked you know I reached out to 90 in
that moment I went to the Niantic
website to see how we can get more Pokey
ghost stops right because I'm like this
is a structural issue it can be fixed
right
um it's designed excuse me it's a design
issue it can be fixed and so I noticed
that there was like a list of things
that made a space eligible um so it has
to be a landmark of some significance
um there had to be sidewalks you know so
folks could access it
um but then the third one is that it had
to be an area that was deemed safe so
given the narratives of what we know
about the south side of Chicago
um you know there there it wasn't going
to be a safe space right and so because
they relied on you know police data hot
spot data to generate you know this this
this idea of safe of safeness and I was
like well surely this this can't be
reality so this is when I reached out to
Niantic I'm like Niantic y'all got to do
something about this because you might
think that you have you know this
beautiful however you create your
overlay however you design this
experience the real world is impacting
the realities of your digital
experiences so here especially on the
south side of Chicago we've got legacies
of redlining we've got legacies of
housing discrimination we've got
legacies of Jim Crow we've got we've got
all these different kinds of um you know
we've got legacies of like white flight
and divestment I was like so all of
these things are happening and they're
not creating equal and Equitable like
experiences across um across the um
across the map right
um and so what I did I was like well I
can
we can kind of create our own uh the
information for our landmarks because
it's it's Chicago there's so much
beautiful history and so many things
that these young folks could actually
engage in and and can actually do uh
where is that where's oh let's see let's
see okay I'm not there yet my bad
um and so the other thing let me tell
you about about these Maps here so
Pokemon go you know really relies on
like the public Wi-Fi um like to operate
and so if you want to look at the city
of Chicago if you were to look at the
Wi-Fi
um hotspot map like it's full of these
blue dots on the north side of the city
and this was that blue dot that's on
that on the left map that was like our
closest Wi-Fi and so these young folks
really were relying on um the public
infrastructure or the brick and mortar
libraries in order you know because if
they're around the space and they still
have connection
um internet connectivity and so um like
in the Summers and after school they
were really relying on on these public
infrastructures which shows the
importance of them right
um especially when you don't have you
know fiber optics and Broad band and
Wi-Fi and whenever the you know the
digital infrastructure is not there we
have to rely on on the traditional brick
and mortar
um and so this was like you know this
project that that we um that I thought
was necessary to include like the
community and in the community with
because while we were looking for
Pokemon go uh stops
um yes we relied on the public library
but we also relied on this organization
called mask this is Mothers and Men
against senseless killing so anytime
people want to talk about like all the
murders and death like in Chicago they
just assume nobody's working to kind of
work on that problem that's just that's
just not true there's so many you know
committed folks and so many Community
organizations and like non-profits that
are woman-led and black LED you know to
do something you know to curb like that
violence and this is one of them but
basically what these black women are
doing they're just occupying you know
the street corners they they occupy the
blog to make sure that kids are just
safe just across the street and I think
that that's one of those conversations
that we don't talk enough about like in
design spaces and Tech spaces of how you
know they create these experiences but
they don't think about then how is that
relaying you know how is that then
unfolding and manifesting like in these
physical spaces where so much of the
real world is still happening like all
those things I just said like that red
lining you know like uh like Jim Crow
um all those things you know still
matter so basically what these women
would do like I said they would just be
on the street corners making sure the
kids like cross the street and then we
use walkie-talkies to talk with one
another say yes let's say you know a kid
like Jerome is at 63rd and he's trying
to get to 64th and there's somebody that
makes sure that he gets there in time
and gets there safely
um and and also back to back to the
library or back to his house I mean so I
think this is like a really important
part of like the work that I'm doing
right now
um as that goes into like future
projects related to you know black game
studies you know my continuing to work
with like black cyber feminism you know
just how important like the people are
um you know to to so many of these
projects
um uh let's see how are we further
questions like I I can keep talking my
Michael but I can also I can also stop
there in case folks might want to like
engage and ask some questions
we're getting some questions but I think
you know let me keep going let me keep
going for 10 more minutes and then okay
okay perfect okay good deal
um one of the things that that guides
like a lot of this work right here you
know I'm really focused on these
Geographic geographically isolated
populations for a lot of reasons right I
needed I needed a framework that would
let me think about
um you know the folks in Appalachia you
know I'm from Kentucky I'm born and
raised in Kentucky but it'll allow me to
think about Appalachia but it will allow
me also to simultaneously think about
like you know south side of Chicago and
I would also you know make me think
about you know I spent a lot of time
like in Arizona and I was connected to
like a lot of the uh a lot of the Native
and Indigenous populations like on the
reservations so I had to really think
about what is like the unifying thread
you know that that kind of helped um
make sense about the exclusionary
practices around the technology
um in these spaces and I'm like these
populations they're geographically
isolated here you know in in Arizona you
know the um whenever I was working with
folks they're in close proximity to
Phoenix Arizona that's a city you know
and the south side of Chicago that's
right there in the Chicagoland all right
it's right there in Chicago area and so
you know it doesn't make sense you know
why why these populations are still the
the so-called you know poster Children
of the digital odd you know um but I'm
like there are some things that are
happening to them intentionally these
things are designed intentionally like
to keep them excluded I mean so how do
we work around that in order to allow
folks to still participate
um so here's some of the guiding
questions here so how do geographically
isolated populations utilize publicly
available tools and Technology to
develop hybrid networks across
communities I love to see what people
piecemeal together in the face of all
these exclusionary practices like if
they don't have the internet if they
don't have connectivity if they don't
have this that or the other but then
they still participate I want to examine
like the architecture of what allows and
enables them to still participate
another question that guides my work
right now how have these hybrid networks
influenced and developed the creation of
culturally sustained spaces
um and so that's one of the things that
I think is very important especially as
Scholars and researchers like when we do
this work you know what kind of like
competencies have we developed in order
to engage
um and engage with these folks so we
don't come from a deficit model right
where we don't come from like well they
don't have computers at home but how are
they learning how to participate they
don't have this they don't have that and
I think those are like the wrong
questions to like approach a lot of
these a lot of these things with right
you know marginalizing minorities
populations are very Savvy in their
internet using their technology use and
I think we should start there start
there from where they are and see what
their capacities are and then we build
out from that right instead of going
coming straight from like well they
don't have this they don't have that so
surely they're not doing these things
when I was doing this project um like
with gaming in the um in the Appalachian
region you know like up in the mountains
of Appalachian you know kind of close to
the West Virginia like hoarder and then
there of course there are all kinds of
assumptions about these poor white folks
and what they don't have and what they
can't do but oh and that's just
incongruent with their realities because
they're still participating they're
still finding ways to connect there's
still um they're they're still finding
ways to like engage and I think those
things need to be showcased right
um another question how do the
culturally sustaining spaces impact how
communities develop computational maker
practices basically how are they
creating and they don't have anything
um and this is where the Reliance on
mobile technologies actually is is
really significant in a lot of those
spaces
um
um I remember one of the events that I
had we took some alien Wares like some
of the gaming computers and we couldn't
run them but we had phones and so we had
to just make do with like games like on
the phone because there were some cell
towers nearby and so they were able to
participate so here I am having to like
reimagine and refashion like this
curriculum that we built out um but also
having to be ready for those
technological like challenges
um and so and then we we really created
these really really beautiful like
experiences
um oh my batteries walking on like the
same no no no no
um and that's where you know I started
to like develop more savviness like
around like the mobile games and the
mobile apps and um and that's why I hate
when a lot of these companies take away
these mobile experiences because when
they take away the mobile experiences
like for instance like fortnite you
remember the fortnite Apple
um so that actually impacted like a lot
of like the the connectivity that these
young folks had because they couldn't
play fortnite like on consoles they were
playing fortnite in Call of Duty and all
these games like on there on their cell
phones uh but then because of that that
issue that Apple was um that a lot of
the companies were having
um with the pay structure on these these
uh app stores you know that that option
was like taken away
um what are the everyday activities in
forming youth computational thinking and
making practices and then across these
sites what are the intersectional design
principles influencing prolonged
engagement with the culturally
sustaining computational maker spaces
one of the um one of the projects that
I'm working on right now here in
Kentucky that actually fits with a lot
of this work that I'm doing they they
just recently uncovered some of the uh
the old segregated cemeteries so where
black folks are you know formerly
enslaved folks but also just like um
because I think cemeteries were mostly
segregated like up until like the 1970s
and 80s like in the country
um and so so many peoples like loved
ones like are buried in these spaces
that they don't have access to you know
so we've um we've working with the
cities you know we're getting um we're
clearing out the areas cutting down like
the trees cutting down like the over the
overgrowth um cleaning up you know we
were just out there with like brushes
and toothbrushes like cleaning off like
the headstones but I also think that
it's important that we we digitize these
kinds of things you know so folks who
aren't able to go to that space you know
can still interact and engage but also
it's like just a part of like you know
archiving you know the memory and the
knowledge and the histories um because
so much of his is being lost and it's
being like eroded um so some of these um
so one of these young folks like here in
the schools that were doing one um
they're going to create they're trying
to create like an AR experience because
some of the headstones are just so so
worn that we don't even know like who
they are so we're going to so what they
want to do is like whenever you go up to
the cemetery in The Headstone you can
kind of like do you can kind of
interface probably hopefully with a QR
code
um and then then it pops up like who
that person is you can see it legibly
um and then we're gonna you know go
through the archives and go through like
the databases like to find out like who
these folks are
um and connect them with like their
families and reconnect them with like
communities and stuff you know so we're
using you know AR augmented reality a
lot for um for a lot of those
experiences but it's really beautiful
what these kids will come up with
um and that's why you know I don't come
from this deficit model anymore like
these kids are Savvy and they they have
really beautiful ideas like to share in
those spaces
um and that's more like Pokemon Go stuff
so here's some of that AR
um
technology that that we're um uh
enabling and you know teaching like the
kids to use
um and it's so many cool like
Technologies
um that we don't have to rely on
somebody else to do this experience to
create the experiences for us you know
we can create them ourselves and I think
that's what's what's really beautiful
uh let's see I think that's my okay I've
come I've come to the end
um and hopefully hopefully folks got
something out of all that let me stop
the share so I can see you all again
let's see where are you all there you
are okay
all right thank you so much for for
sharing all of that we do have a set of
questions that I'm going to just start
diving into
um
uh these are not in the order that
they've been submitted but just sort of
popping around a little bit uh just
wondering what are some guidelines that
you could suggest to designers and
researchers who aren't brown or black of
social systems to become aware of
minority experiences that are
particularly underrepresented in
mainstream media so they can proactively
design for these populations rather than
doing this afterthought oh my gosh
that's a million dollar question right
oh gosh I think one of the things that's
important is to be intentional up front
with with audiences that's why you know
part of that intersectional game design
you know I'm big about you know the
authentic experiences for Who Who Are
You designing this for
um and that's why you know I I remember
talking earlier with somebody and they
said well I'm just designing it for
anybody that's just not true we aren't
just designing for anybody so we have to
really be intentional about when we're
designing who we're creating for who can
participate who can't participate who's
going to be left out and so we actually
have to do that reflective exercise like
early on if we're like well I'm going to
create this experience for this
particular demographic like just name
that and claim that and own that right
but if you're actually wanting to to
diversify like audiences and stuff you
know you're gonna have to bring those
folks to the table early on right you're
going to have to have like listening
sessions of where you're where you ask
people what historically has been your
experience around this thing right
um and then you're gonna have to like
listen
listen and not be um oh how can I say
this not be in your feelings a lot when
people say these hard things to you
right
um I remember working with this one
company one time and I'll bless them
their feelings kept getting hurt they
kept well they were saying that what
we're doing is racist and it's not
racism I'm like okay stop just ignore
that they said that I'm like because I
can spend more time to help you
understand that part and that piece but
I think that's what stops so much of the
work right because communities
especially minorities marginalized
communities have experienced so much
harm and there's never been a place
where we Rectify that harm so whenever
they finally get into a space where they
can speak them or they can Advocate a
lot of times it might seem harsh of
where they're they're they're they're
they're laying they're giving you all of
their grievances that they've had over
over a time but I think as you know
committed researchers and makers and
doers like in this space we have to just
acknowledge like yes you've been
excluded we're trying to fix that yes we
hear you right and so I think there you
just have to just sit and listen and
like take a take a lot in them because
then you're gonna find those flashes of
really creation and Innovation is going
to come after they after they get that
out and then you can you know get to the
work of like making and creating But
first you got to bring these folks to
the table
if you don't have like a budget uh first
of all I would say pay folks like in a
consultant you know kind of kind of like
manner but if you don't then just make
and create the experiences with them
just like I did with those like I'm not
gonna assume anything about like poor
white folks like an Appalachia because
that's not my reality and that's not my
experience so I make the relationships
with them I go out there with them even
with their Confederate flags out front
of their house I'm gonna go in there
we're gonna play these video games
right
um so so I think there's a lot that goes
on like in oh my gosh I remember going
um where was it at Harlan County I
remember going um to like this after
school kind of program and you know they
had belt buckles with Confederate flags
the trucks had Confederate flags and I'm
like all right we're in it this is it I
was like um but you know I didn't feel I
didn't feel like my life was in danger I
want to make sure that folks know that
clear
um because I had already made a
relationship with the young folks and
with their families and with their
parents and they knew I was there to
help and to support and um and so I
think the relationship building
um is really like the core piece if you
got a relationship with folks um it's
much easier to do a lot of this work
yeah
I'm synthesizing a couple questions here
uh but there are there are a couple
questions around
do you how much of this is methods and
how much of this is awareness is maybe
the the thrust of it like are there
methods that we can be better teaching
or to what extent you know if you had to
split your attention between the methods
and just discussion and and adding
awareness in the game industry you know
what what's going to be the intervention
that you think is going to help the most
um so intersectional Tech I think is in
part A methods book right so I spent a
lot of time talking about the challenges
of like doing this work
um and even in this body like it's not
it's not easy even though I'm black and
I do like a lot of research like on
black people like these are not easy
like conversations like to have because
I acknowledge and recognize like all of
my institutional privilege uh economic
privilege you know I recognize that
there are some differences here right in
our lived experiences and realities like
are not the same so a lot of it you know
has to just be intentional about who are
you engaging with right
um and we got to do like and as part of
like methods right so let's say you want
to go and do some work on like young
black folks in there how they learn
technology you know what work have you
done
um to understand you know what their
what the realities are what the stories
are
um because this this isn't just brand
this isn't brand new stuff nothing that
we do is look brand new and I think that
that's something that we have to like
acknowledge
um you might be approaching it like in a
different way but there are people who
have done this and asked similar
questions and then similar things so
let's go and do our homework and get up
to speed on what the conversations are
so we don't go in these spaces and do
more harm
um because a lot of academic
institutions they do a lot of extractive
work let's let's be honest a lot of what
we do is very extractive it's very
exploitative right we're going in inside
these communities and inside these
populations and we're asking them for
things to help with our research so we
can Pat our CVS and so we can build our
bodies of research
um and so I think it's it's important to
like acknowledge and that should be like
a part of like the conversation like
around methods like ethics should be
embedded into every week that we do it
shouldn't just be you know week two
where we kind of gloss over it and then
we go into like the realness of it the
ethics is a part of like that real work
as well
um I also found that a lot of the
methods were incongruence with what I
um with with with with what I wanted to
do and what I wanted to accomplish right
right
so there was like a there's a part in
intersectional Tech where I talk a harm
is happening happened to this black man
and here I am I'm wanting to ask
questions I'm wanting to engage in the
researcher part but I don't I take a
step back and I just there I'm just
there and then I offer support
um I remember you know one of my
advisors was like you know kashani
should ask the questions you could I I'm
like I'm I'm answering no tabloids here
like what you think we doing you know
that and so and that's why I was just
like I'm I had to I had to come up with
um uh like intersectional design
basically to
um to account for those kind of
hierarchical structural structures and
like practices inside our research
methods we had to go away from the
positivists you know so what there are
no biases there there are no assumptions
yeah yeah there are yeah like we
shouldn't go into this thinking that
thinking that none of those things exist
yeah they do because we're human beings
and we're going into spaces like with
other human beings now remember there
was also like a mentor that said well
Keyshawn that's why I don't do humans
I'm like what you mean you don't do
humans I don't want to talk to humans I
just want to be over here this
technology because humans are too hard
I'll say okay will you just stay over
there and I'll be over here
um because I think humans are actually
fascinating and I think if we talk to
More Humans we could build better
Technologies and build better things if
we spent more time with the humans yeah
I hope that helped yeah uh next question
is
who's asking
even if we think Tech products are
designed for everyone quote unquote
they're often tested on a specific
majority demographic and then there are
ramifications for folks outside of that
tested population are are there any
products or systems that you can think
of that are directed or designed or
tested for the quote-unquote actual
population of use and specifically tech
for minority groups
oh my gosh
I know a lot of things that have been
designed without including minority
groups but specifically including
minority groups my goodness I'm sure
there are oh yeah gaming gives us great
examples the Adaptive controller you
know especially to be more more
inclusive and more accessible like with
people who have like you know different
disabilities and stuff you know
different use of their hands
um I remember doing um uh interviewing
um they're called the quad Gods there's
like a group of Gamers they're
quadriplegic and they talk about
um you know just how costly it is to
just participate in gaming you know
because when they buy like a console you
know they have it and then it comes with
like you know the standard controller
you all know what like a controller
looks like but they can't use the
controller right they can't use the
traditional headset right you know
because they have you know very limited
use of like their arms very limited use
of like their legs and stuff and so
they're talking about like the cost that
it the cost to just gain entry inside
the console space
um and all the attachments and all all
the things that they have to buy to just
be able to talk and to be able to
participate and be able to engage in
that space so there are some controllers
that it's like third-party stuff right
I'm wanting that to be more of the norm
in the OG experience so like when you
design this phone for me I want to know
I don't want to have to go and add you
know all kinds of things in order to to
just talk on my phone and use my phone
whenever Apple gives makes this laptop
for me I don't want to have to go buy
all these extra like attachments and
things just to participate so I think
that we're getting there I can't I can't
name anything outside of the Adaptive
controller that actually you know
thought about you know what's I thought
about like accessibility you know either
you know from the from um uh from like
the standpoint of like disability or
even like racial accessibility which is
what I talk about like in the classroom
like oh let me y'all might be interested
in this
I've been doing I'm not a Dei person but
you know folks of color they'll throw us
in the Des base so they threw me in this
Des space and you know they wanted to
say you know what what do we need to be
thinking about like in higher education
and like in universities right now and I
said well you know those letters of of
accommodation the disabled students get
right I was like we need to think about
something similar when it comes to like
racial accommodations they're like what
do you mean and I was like what we
should like design we should think about
you know like if um because like I'm at
the University of Kentucky I'm not sure
if you all remember last semester
um one of our black women
um uh workers uh in in housing she was
accosted called it in where like it was
a really awful like you know kind of
like experience for her and then so and
then the next day you know the campuses
went like back to normal and I was like
you know what was like them what was
what kind of space did we take for like
black students and other students who
were like negatively like impacted for
that and they're like well that's an
individual thing that happened to that
individual I'm like no no no but we felt
that Collective Lee we all felt that
collectively so then so in my mind I'm
like you know I think universities
should like really come up with like hey
this is like what the policy should be
if like this racial harm happened we'll
take the time and hold space and this is
where you can go if you need like help
and support they thought I was talking
like another language all together I'm
like y'all don't y'all ain't about that
life anyways let me go on back to my
research let me go back to my lab and
play these video games because they
wasn't about their life at all I can't
do diab anyway next next question so I
hope that answered it didn't answer your
question because I don't have examples
hopefully somebody in a space can think
of examples
um fashion fashion is doing it like when
I think about
um
think about uh like Adidas Adidas is
like bringing in like black designers
and stuff you know so I know like a lot
of the fashion houses are intentional
about bringing in like diverse designers
like to create different kinds of
experiences but number one in Council
like technology
I I can't think of any
I can't
well they're out they gotta be out there
right they got to be out there like I'm
I'm if I think of something I'll send
them to see Michael you share yeah
this also teaches us something that it's
that it's that hard the um I think we're
about at times so why don't we wrap it
here and thank Professor gray for
joining us uh and sharing her thoughts
with us again thank you so much we'll
give you silent Zoom claps which is the
most awkward thing uh but yeah we'll do
it anyway
thank you all I appreciate you all so
much yeah thank you for spending part of
your afternoon and your day with us of
course I'm glad to I'm glad too
absolutely see ya